hey Queen how are you I like your pink
sweater I'm wearing it for you I know we
not you know maybe we're not we're still
wearing pink okay but I'm gonna do it
okay I'm gonna do it girl I do
well first of all I'm good how are you
doing I'm good today thanks yeah yeah
okay we're good I like that I like that
um I know that you got to induct Dolly
Parton into the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame and
I just have to ask you what was that
like I know you recorded a song with her
as well
she is just as sweet as you want her to
be she is this big
um she's incredible she's just she's
very present and that night was wild I
mean the performances were incredible
it was a very pinch yourself kind of
evening
dolly is a legend to so many people
um what does it feel like knowing that
you are so many people's Dolly like you
are a legend too in your own right
so I feel like oh that's weird I don't
know I don't know but I feel like
people love dolly in a
like like you love a family member kind
of way like a real real deep way and
I for me I feel like I have a
relationship with I've grown up kind of
with the people that listen to me and
and I go and I see familiar faces it
shows a lot and
I feel like we have a really honest
dialogue between ourselves between
between us and it's like group therapy
we've all been joining in on together
for 20 years and it's wonderful it's
wonderful it's a blessing it's an honor
yeah I can say that I'm in the group
therapy sessions thank you yay
especially this album trust fall I will
say I cried as someone who's dealing
with her own grief I will say I cried to
like four of the songs but not not like
a sad cry a happy like therapeutic cry
um what was your approach with this
album because it felt like really
healing
it was that it was there was a lot going
on I took three years to make this album
and I you know I lost my dad and I lost
a very very dear friend eight months
later and it's a pandemic I'm raising
children and my son is sick and
it's just so much going on it's adulting
is a lot and it is at the same time I'm
writing these songs and I'm writing the
experience and
I think life is a you know it's a roller
coaster and I'm here for all of it yeah
the album name is called trust fall of
course um who in your own life do you
just trust to catch you when you fall me
oh I like that
it's the best answer
boom if you're talking just blatant
trust me but by my kids you know not
that it's their job but I think if they
had the muscles they would fully catch
me oh
do you still get nerves before you step
on stage because you're doing shows like
50 000 fans in an arena stadiums like
it's nuts no I I get nervous on TV when
I only get one song because that's like
a warm-up that's when I get nervous I'm
like I'm not even gonna be sweating by
the time I'm off that stage
but no when I'm under the stage like
I'll be my two riggers on each side of
me I'm in a harness they're holding me
down I know I'm about to get launched
and I'm sitting there going
am I sad I feel like I might be am I sad
today I'm sad today
and Willow laughed and she was crying
and she didn't like that chocolate I
gave her and
then when you're like
anymore
so no I don't have a chance to be
nervous
uh what does it mean to have a support
system for you
um I have really good friends I have a
great support system yeah I don't keep
yes people around me
um I don't I mean I have very very deep
authentic relationships
with my crew and also I've been with
like the people that I work with around
we've been together 20 years my newest
band member is my drummer and he's you
know but everybody else it's like 13
years 21 years yeah
I feel like you would have
sorry I just believe in longevity oh yes
I feel like you would have a really good
um detector I feel like you can
just a mile away like I can just tell
him
a mile away
um do you still do your own grocery
shopping because okay my video
I do and yesterday morning I was in the
grocery store and this guy in front of
me was dressed in all San Francisco
49ers gear and I'm a Philly girl so yeah
he got so mad I almost bought his chips
for him that's how mad he was but yeah
oh I don't know so you're excited you're
excited about the Super Bowl
oh I'm excited are we outside last time
the Eagles were at the Super Bowl I sang
the national anthem and they won so
wait they have to call you no it's going
to be Chris Stapleton this time they
chose correctly
[Laughter]
um I have to say so your real life
trainer is featured in the music video
and on a scale of one to ten like how
badly does she kick your butt in
sessions
Jeanette is a warrior princess who also
happens to be Canadian oh is such a
badass I love her so much and
most people when I say no they listen
she does not
hear me
the dance break in this video feels like
a call back to there she go which I
remember very vividly
um such a such a good moment I love that
you got that that's exactly what I
wanted I told the choreographers I was
like go watch the There You Go video and
and give me a dance oh my gosh what do
you remember most about filming your
first video
so fun Christian the cute boy I remember
him
I just remember going like I can't
believe they're gonna put enough money
into this video that I get to Launch
two motorcycles off of a downtown
building in Los Angeles
um
and then my makeup artist Billy B at the
time when I jumped off the motorcycle
right before it launches every take he
would be like look at her ass
it was a fun video to make that's a fond
memory yeah
oh this song is about not letting your
insecurity stop you from living your
best life so what did you learn to let
go of
with your insecurities what is something
that you let go of and when did you
learn it
oh boy
um I I think with age it just happens
right like when I was in my 20s I was
like I have to be this weight
and then in your 30s you have a kid and
you're like well maybe I could just be
this way and then you're in your 40s and
you've had two kids and you're like
sweet and you just take yourself way
less seriously because you know you're
gonna mess up you know you're gonna
apologize you know you're gonna try your
best and the rest is in God's hands
period
this is your 50th music video yeah what
how crazy is that like I can't even
looking back at all your music videos
and not including the last one what
would you say is your fave and your not
so fave
um
um I would say try is up there yeah
just because of the physicality and it's
so beautiful beautiful and I was a
female director Gloria sigismundi she's
incredible and
and then my not favorite maybe the
SpongeBob we've got
this is SpongeBob but everybody's got
one it's like a hooker pirate or
something it was weird
so I've done some weird things that was
an amazing answer that was everything
that I needed
I don't hook up I never heard of that
hooker Pirates crazy
and lastly
um please don't watch it that's not an
invitation for everyone to go and watch
it oh in swarms in swarms
please don't watch it do you find music
is a form of therapy for you like
writing and recording and yeah 100 100
percent that's what it is music is
medicine it's the one universal language
and it's a it's sort of a Gateway
straight into your feelings we all have
to put our feelings away so much of the
day it's just
and you put on that song that one song
whatever that is for you and you're just
you're just instantly connected back to
your true self yeah do you have a like
one song that you listen to that just
gets you like puts you in the best mood
in the best mood yeah oh gosh
um
hey yeah by Outkast yes all right all
right all right yes that's the one I
think that might be mine too it's just
you can't be mad when that song's on no
you can't pink it was so nice to talk to
you this album is incredible another
amazing body of work yet again you just
be giving it to us so we appreciate you
Queen we really do
thank you thanks guys